[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le premier ministre jean
castex annoncé jeudi dernier un gel des
tarifs du gaz et de l'électricité cet
hiver pour protéger les français pendant
un certain temps du moins de
l'augmentation continuelle du prix de
l'énergie le gaz et l'électricité on l'a
vu mais aussi le charbon et les sens qui
atteint la barre symbolique de deux
euros le litre dans quelques stations
service aujourd'hui encore le prix du
gaz s'est envolée sur les marchés
européens alors que les présidents et
chefs de gouvernement étaient réunis en
slovénie pour parler notamment du
problème alors pourquoi de telles
augmentations allons nous connaître des
coupures d'électricité à répétition
comme en chine y aura-t-il assez
d'énergie pour que l'économie mondiale
repartent après un an et demi deux
pandémies pour débattre nous avons
invité jean-pierre favennec vous êtes
professeur à l'école nationale
supérieure du pétrole et des moteurs
l'ifp school vous êtes un spécialiste de
l'énergie on vous doit notamment un
atlas mondial des énergies chez armand
colin en deux mots pour vous pourquoi
les les prix de l'énergie formative en
ce moment c'est demande est très forte
demande est très forte et un paravent
les productions ne suivent pas donc on
va reparler demande très forte mais
vraiment impressionnant vous avez dit
que le prix l'énergie le prix du gaz
aujourd'hui avec complètement explosé à
passer ces n'arrive à des niveaux
faramineux qu'on n'a jamais vus c'est un
bug choc pétrolier de 73 mais pour le
oui c'est presque sa saga fois quasiment
chauve et 3,73 à chaque politique mais
rien d y en ad'autres pas politique
femme un peu politique mais pas trop
celui de liés à la révolution islamique
en iran départ du chalet mais ni le
premier ni mais là on est vraiment sur
une explosion complet ce prix du gaz
thomas reverdy vous êtes sociologues des
organisations et des marchés vous
enseignez à grenoble inp et à l'école de
génie industriel et à polytechnique vous
êtes l'auteur d' un antimanuel de
management de projets paru chez dunod
mais aussi d'un livre sur la
construction politique du prix de
l'énergie aux presses de sciences po
alors pourquoi les prix de l'énergie
augmentent il d'après vous à moi je
réponde pour les prix l'électricité le
marché des tristes et c'est un marché où
les prix peuvent être extrêmement
variables extrêmement volatile sur le
court terme
sur le long terme et ils réagissent
énormément aux situations de
surcapacités ou au contraire de capacité
insuffisante et puis la deuxième raison
c'est que la france ses consommateurs
français est de plus en plus exposés aux
prix de marché européen et ça ce sont
plutôt des choix institutionnels et
politiques et on pourra détaillé par la
suite c'est chaud on va revenir
effectivement sur le marché européen at
the bridge as vous êtes un jeune
ingénieur chercheuse à edf ressources et
développement vous êtes membre du
syndicat sud énergie pour vous pourquoi
est-ce que ça flambe
oui ça a été dit pour le gaz c'est une
question principalement de devant
quelque chose par contre pour
l'électricité c'est pas ça à la demande
est très stable les coûts de production
augmentent peu donc c'est vraiment à
cause d'un mécanisme de marché
complètement inadaptés auditoire à
revenir alors commençons par le gaz
la demande explose c'est sur la reprise
économique en asie notamment fait que
tout bout de voeux du gaz
enfin on le disait ça le prix du gaz sur
les marchés national a été multipliée à
peu près je crois choses comme ça au
moins on en attend aujourd'hui oui voilà
et
alors là on sait qu'on n'accuse en
général la russie oui est le plus gros
producteur de gaz du monde oui ne pas
nous en fournir assez oui on est là la
russie représente le marché européen
dépend 1 40% des exportations us en gros
la russie nous fournit 40% à l'europe du
gaz que l'on consomme donc on soupçonne
peut-être monsieur poutine de jouer un
petit peu avec ça un peu surprenant tout
ça puisque dans en fasse normalement
rien eu il n'a certaine abondance de gaz
donc ce que vous avez cités problème de
l'aco vide le problème il ya une chose
qui doit jouer c'est le fait que les les
la logistique ne suis pas complètement
si on voit les pannes d'électricité en
chine c'est totalement impressionnants
donc il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas
totalement connues ou maman alors il ya
peut-être une fée qui pour une petite
manipulation du prix du gaz mais je
crois qu'on est vraiment sur des marchés
en parler du marché de l'électricité
selon elle a bien cité hoche électricité
effectivement on a des variations qui
vont de l'indicé des prix négatifs sur
le prix électricité ça arrive souvent
parce que les allemands a certainement
profité mandat est restée savent pas
comment faire pour qu'ils paient des
gens pour empêcher si on regarde au
mégot est le prix du mégawattheure selon
les quarts d'heure
du simple à 10 fois et c'est même
négatif à certains moments pour le gaz
on n'en est pas là est le problème est
pas tout à fait le même mais pour le gaz
on a effectivement là il aurait eu une
éruption du prix du gaz qui s'explique
difficilement parce que même si l'on
sait qu'il faut refaire des stocks de
gaz pour faire face à l'hiver même si
l'on sait quel poids sens économique
très forte qu'à une consommation on voit
bien que dans d'autres secteurs il ment
non pas du gaz et par exemple des pièces
pour faire les voitures etc le reste
serait ça reste suffisant pour moi je
disais jusqu'à y à l'époque récente il y
avait du gaz y en a un peu partout si
vous voulez on parlait du gaz de schiste
américain qui semblait devoir inondé la
planète et d'un seul coup on se retrouve
avec une espèce de pénurie par est ce
que les américains eux mêmes d'ailleurs
il semble qu'aux états unis il ya un peu
de difficulté à reprendre un petit peu
tout ça pour ce qui fait qu'il ya pour
le moment en tout cas à l'instant t il
n'y a pas assez de garer la chine part
de la chine a annoncé qu à y renoncer à
ces à ses centrales à charbon
elle a besoin de plus de gaz a besoin de
plus de 13 à organiser les jeux camping
tout à fait donc là aussi pas de charbon
ben c'est un peu comme si c'est passé en
2008 elle avait arrêté les centrales au
charbon aux environs de pékin pour
limiter la pollution est donc là il ya
de nouveau des jeux olympiques d'hiver
donc il y as certainement une volonté de
passer d'arrêter des centrales vient de
passer des centrales au gaz et donc ça
attire terriblement la consommation de
gaz au savoir qu'en chine elle consomme
quelque chose mais donner un chiffre va
pas d'être aux chiffres mais est à peu
près de 2 milliards de tonnes de charbon
on voir un peu plus qu'ils sont
consommés chaque année tout ça pour être
en principe remplacé en grande partie
par du gaz et vous voyez ça
représenterait si elle aussi la chine
décidé je prends un exemple stupide de
tout remplacer le charbon par du gaz
c'est la moitié de la demande mondiale
de gaz qui serait nécessaire donc on
voit bien qu'ils la chine décide
vraiment de réduire sa consommation de
charbon pour faire de l'électricité plus
propres et veut passer au gaz ça va
tirer terriblement alors si on vit à la
russie qui a signé un très gros contrat
avec le ciment
la russie et les anciennes les européens
donc ça c'est pas très bon pour nous et
puis à toutes les histoires autour de
nord stream de tout à fait tout ça fait
que est-ce que la russie pourrait nous
fournir plus de gaz devrait sans mal
pourrait nous en fournir un peu plus
sachant que la russie fectivement
salaces et devient très politique ça
remonte à 2014 donc la révolution de mai
dont elle est la situation en basse et
donc la russie traditionnellement
envoyait son gaz vers l'europe à travers
l'ukraine vont déjà depuis 2010 avec eux
c'est le chancelier schröder allemand
qui avait pris la tête d'un consortium
avec les russes pour construire ce qu'on
appelle nordstream 1-1 'pipeline' ira
mal quand même pas mal de gaz et là il
ya eu un tout un conflit autour du hub
en prime deux noms scream 2 en fait les
américains n'en voulait pas monsieur
trump est venu voir madame
madame merkel il ya deux ans en lui
disant pourquoi vous fais des affaires
avec vos ennemis donc arrêter d'importer
du gaz russe prenez du gaz américain et
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait
l'administration by donne d'ailleurs est
resté plus ou moins sur cette position
en disant on ne veut pas d'une en stream
2 au dernier moment ça s'est arrangé
donc il ya une espèce de pression
conjointe des russes et des allemands
pour construire ce gazoduc a été
terminée dans la construction a été
terminée qui va bientôt entrer en
fonction mais pour le moment on voit que
tout ça n'est pas suffisant le blé les
chiffres que l'on a ne démontre pas qu
actuellement il n'y a pas assez de gaz
russe sur le marché européen peut-être
que quand il y en a beaucoup qui part
aussi vers l'asie ça ça peut jouer les
chiffres sur ta à vérifier de près alors
sur le gaz tamar et verdi
sur le gaz je me prononcerai pas je
pense explications ont été ont été très
bonnes et effectivement on a un mix par
exemple le mix électrique qui est de
plus en plus consommateurs de gaz le gaz
et permet à la fois la réduction des
émissions de carbone par rapport au
charbon et le gaz permet aussi une
flexibilité des installations très
flexible qui permette de de faire face
aux intermittents ces énergies
renouvelables donc on peut avoir
globalement en europe une augmentation
de la consommation de gaz on peut enfin
elle va être elle va être significative
un mot sur le gaz
oui enfin à long terme on va quand même
devoir s'en passer on a un objectif de
neutralité carbone à 2050 et donc on va
aller vers des gaz de synthèse ou des
biogaz donc à terme on va devenir
indépendant de ses ressources fossiles
alors je pense qu'effectivement ça a
expliqué les différentes raisons
effectivement l'attention sur sur la
demande qui font augmenter les prix du
gaz ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il faut aller
vers des contrats à long terme négociés
par les acteurs les plus gros possible
et par contre stabiliser les prix pour
les usagers
d'accord parce que il ya aussi on n'en a
pas parlé mais c'est vrai que c'est une
filière où il ya eu peu
d'investissements ces dernières années
dans le gaz ouais il ya dédiés à des
projets très importants qui sont eux qui
sont à l'étude un banal mozambique est
une énorme ressources de gaz
au large des côtes ouest africaines le
gaz de schiste était en normalement
quelque chose je ne prononcerai pas sur
l'aspect environnemental de la chose et
beaucoup discussion il ya un potentiel
de gaz que vous dites effectivement un
jour ou l'autre franck est arrêté
maintenant faut peut-être commencer par
était d'abord le charbon ensuite un peu
le pétrole et puis le gaz lahille
l'agent sapin sur l'énergie disait il y
a dix ans le gaz est une bonne
transition vers justement monde
décarboné mais les choses vont tellement
vite évoluer je reconnais récemment que
je viens de faire deux jours de cours à
des étudiants sont les enjeux
énergétiques et des moments je sais plus
très bien où on en est ce que l'on voit
c'est qu'il faut aller très très vite
aller au rapport du giec il remonte un
peu de temps il dit arrêtez tout l'aï
vue elle même a dit il n'ya pas
longtemps arrêté toute nouvelle
exploitation de pétrole et de gaz
maintenant je comprends très bien cette
situation d'un point de vue protection
d'environnement c'est sans doute
nécessaire d'un point de vue survie d'un
certain nombre de pays à court terme
nous peut-être qu'en europe on peut
décider
on peut décider de bloquer ma voiture de
m'obliger à faire du vélo c'est pas
prudent peut-être mais pour tout un tas
de raisons mais par contre ya un certain
nombre de pays ou de toute façon les
consommations sont très faibles il ya un
minimum de demande qui est à raquettes à
satisfaire pour passer les les gaz de
synthèse des biogaz etc l'autre jour
j'assiste à une eau mais aussi à une
assise une émission on voyait bien que
toute énergie pose des problèmes crois
que c'est c'est très bien de vouloir se
passer des énergies fossiles y aura
moins de co2 passer au tout électrique
etc va poser d'autres problèmes alors
évidemment limiter les émissions de co2
c'est important parce que l'augmentation
de la température est certainement
quelque chose d'assez catastrophique les
autres énergies et je ne suis pas peu
dire pour dire qu'il faut conserver le
pétrole et le gaz je suis là pour dire
simplement que toutes les énergies aux
énormément de problème est que quand on
voit par exemple prendre des éoliennes
c'est pas évident à gérer de toute façon
la population commence à basculer contre
les éoliennes je ne dis pas que c'est
bon mais je dis voilà alors que le prix
du gaz augmente le prix de l'électricité
aussi thomas rey vernis vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi
il ya effectivement d'abord ce qui
augmente ce n'est pas forcément le prix
est restée il faut garder un petit peu
plus en détail de quoi il s'agit il
s'agit du prix de marché de gros de
l'électricité qui augmente avec le prix
du gaz ceci pour deux raisons
la première raison c'est que on quand il
y a la première raison actuellement
c'est que on est dans des situations de
capacité de moins en moins importante
d'électricité au regard éventuellement
de la demande et que on va donc
solliciter de plus en plus souvent ces
installations qui fonctionnent au gaz et
donc le prix le coût de ces
installations se reflète de plus en plus
souvent dans le prix de marché de gros
de l'électricité et
donc ça entraîne à la hausse ce prix de
marché de gros de l'électricité ce prix
aussi entraîné à la hausse par le fait
qu' il
reflète aussi une autre variable qui est
le coût du co2 ou plutôt le nez permis
les quotas d'émissions de co2 qui est un
dispositif qui a été mis en place en
europe pour encourager la réduction des
émissions de co2 et qui d'ailleurs
contribuer au basculement de l'usaj du
charbon pour produire d'électricité vers
vers le gaz donc on a ces deux variables
clés le prix du gaz le prix du co2 et l'
usage de plus en plus important des
installations au gaz qui sont les
dernières sollicité fait que le prix de
marché de gros européen effectivement
aujourd'hui on a des les valeurs très
élevées qui sont annoncés pour l'année
prochaine on parle d'estimation autour
de 100 euros le mégawatt/heure alors
qu'il y a il ya trois ans on était
plutôt autour de 35 euros le
mégawattheure on se marchait beau ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut
qu'on comprenne en france le mix
énergétique c'est de l'électricité fait
du nucléaire d'abord ensuite c'est de
l'hydraulique un peu tout petit peu
d'éolien et de solaire
audi ou et le gaz là dedans pourquoi
l'électricité en france est influencé
par l'augmentation du prix du gaz et
vous l'avez dit ça c'est le marché c'est
le marché européen de l'énergie et qui
fait que tout à coup les tarifs s'aligne
sur la dernière centrale utilisé au
moment du pic de la demande
voilà c'est bien ça qui est important
c'est le central et le gaz voilà si on
votait dans un monde enfin un marché
totalement libre et si la france était
dans un marché totalement libéralisé et
complètement on verra par la suite ce
n'est pas tout à fait le cas en fait le
prix pour le consommateur sera obligé de
refléter le prix de marché de gros
européen mais on sent bien que ce plan
politique c'est pas force c'est
difficilement acceptable en france de
considérer que le consommateur français
doit et est bien être impactés par un
prix de marché de gros qui se forme qui
sont en europe donc en fait ce problème
là a déjà existé et existent a déjà
existé par le passé il a déjà existé en
gros dans la période entre deux milles
entre 2004-2005 et puis 2008 et est à
l'époque le gouvernement et parlement en
france avait fait un choix politique qui
étaient de protéger le consommateur
vis-à-vis du marché groupe c'est à dire
que on a maintenu le tarif réglementé et
on a décidé que le calcul du tarif
réglementé se ferait on a maintenu un
tarif réglementé qui était calculé sur
la base des coûts de production français
et n'ont pas calé sur un prix de marché
de gros européen ce qu'on fait par
contre les autres pays d'europe et donc
du coup on à protéger le consommateur
d'une première hausse dans cette période
là et
vous voyez c'est un choix politique ce
n'est pas un choix de comment dire
logistique c'est pas un résultat d'un
fai logistique qui serait que
l'électricité en france on y
accéderaient
finalement on accéderait à nos moyens de
production directement en fait le marché
quand il est libéralisée ces mêmes prix
qui s'exerce un peu partout en fait en
europe 1 les tomates espagnoles elles
sans vos prêts au même prix en espagne
en france donc voila et est donc ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'à l'époque on a
fait le choix de maintenir
de préserver de protéger le consommateur
français ce qu'on avait déjà connu des
très fortes hausses des prix sur le
marché européen on a fait le choix de
protéger le consommateur français est et
on a mis en place une sorte
d'échafaudage assez complexe qui est qui
a écrit quelques a permis de conserver
cette protection
and the borgias
oui alors sur le
protection elles existent elles
n'existent que partiellement c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les prix
augmentent depuis depuis un moment
effectivement les prix de marché ont été
mis en place avec l'ouverture des
marchés donc au début des années 2000 ce
sont des prix européens il peut y avoir
des écarts entre pays quand il ya des
congestions sur les interconnexions mais
sinon c'est un prix qui est formé de
manière européenne et vous l'avez
expliqué c'est
la centrale la plus chère à chaque
instant qui détermine dont le coût
variable détermine le prix de marché
donc même si on est à 90 % nucléaire 8%
solaire et éolien et puis 2% gaz et bien
c'est le prix du gaz qui va former le
prix et c'est ce qui se passe en fait
depuis longtemps alors c'est le gaz ou
charbon auquel s'ajoute le prix du co2
qui est une pénalité pour les pour les
productions émettrices de co2 donc ce
prix de marché pose des problèmes depuis
toujours c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
correspond pas du tout aux coûts de
production de systèmes électriques qui
sont essentiellement des coûts fixes les
coûts de production alors en france en
particulier en france on est à 70 %
nucléaire 22% hydraulique c'est presque
des coûts fixes 1 80% à peu près des
coûts sont fixés à dire c'est au moment
de la construction de la centrale que ce
fait les dépenses plus la maintenance et
la part variable qui dépend de la
production est vraiment tout petit et
par exemple le prix du gaz c'est de
l'ordre de 7% sur le système électrique
européen c'est un peu moins vrai parce
que c'est un petit peu il ya un peu plus
de de charbon il ya de production à
charbon et à gaz mais ça reste quand
même vrai c'est essentiellement des
coûts fixes et effectivement si on
n'avait pas libéralisé aujourd'hui les
tarifs des usagers refléterait toujours
les coûts de production et donc
varierait très lentement mais à cause de
ceux de ce prix de marché on indexe ses
prix de gros sur une variable qui est
complètement incontrôlable qui est donc
le gaz au prix du gaz et puis le prix du
co2 et les tarifs réglementés qui
jusqu'à 2015 et f comme comme disait
thomas reverdy protéger encore le
consommateur de ces de ces variations
parce qu'elle s'était calée sur les
coûts de production aujourd'hui par la
pression libéralisa trice on va dire de
l'europe et des fournisseurs concurrents
des fournisseurs concurrents
on n'a obtenu qu'une partie de ce tarif
reflète les prix de gros alors
heureusement pour nous ce n'est encore
qu'une petite partie c'est de l'ordre de
10 % du tarif si on si on fait court le
tarif l'ancien tarif bleu c'est un tiers
pour la part énergie un tiers pour la
part transport un tiers pour la part
taxes donc déjà on ne s'occupe que d'à
part énergie et sur cette part énergie
encore un tiers dont finalement à peu
près de 10% de la facture est dépendante
du marché parce qu'on a un coût tout un
système un mécanisme de contournement de
marché commune comme il en existe plein
qui fait que le nucléaire est encore
payé à son coût de production enfin en
tout cas le coup qu'on a estimé fameux
mécanisme de la reine
donc aujourd'hui alors que y'a qu'une
partie du coût qui qui reflète les prix
de marché on a quand même déjà connu des
très forte hausse un mois j'ai regardé
sur cette part énergie donc que qui pour
laquelle un tiers seulement est impacté
par les coûts de marché depuis 2016
entre 2016 et 2000 et 2020 ça a augmenté
de 25% cède pas et là on s'apprête à
nouveau à avoir une grosse hausse sauf
si elle est plafonnée et si on regarde
depuis le début de la libéralisation bon
là c'est 70 60 70 % d'augmentation alors
à chaque fois on nous dit oui mais c'est
pour dc pour des raisons autres c'est
parce qu'il a fallu financer les
énergies renouvelables c'est parce qu'il
a fallu financer le réseau c'est parce
que l'état de sourds menthe si on se
focalise sur la période 2016-2020 oui
c'est ça non oui 2018 excuse-moi
2018-2020 donc les trois les trois
dernières années
il n'ya plus l'augmentation du
financement des énergies renouvelables
ne se reflète plus dans les tar heels a
été plafonné parce que ça augmente est
trop vite donc c'est pas cette raison là
les ce n'est pas non plus à cause des
réseaux c'est vraiment le mécanisme de
marché un pur mécanismes de marché qui
fait que les prix explosent et que ça
devient de plus en plus insupportable au
point où même bruno le maire aujourd'hui
10 les mieux marché de l'électricité est
complètement absurde tu pu caler son
terme aberrant je crois et il faut
revenir dessus c'est bien ça fait ça
fait quinze ans que ça existe mais je
pense que maintenant il est temps
vraiment de revenir à la base sur ce
système alors que les usages et les
grands industriels comme les
particuliers 10 nous un prix stable le
plus stable possible et qui reflètent
les coûts jean pierre favennec comme
vous l'expliqué alors le fait que ce
marché perdure alors qu'il a l'air de
de défavoriser tout bande
ça si vous les jeux je pense qu'il ya eu
je mets tous je dis toujours qu'il ya eu
un changement violent dans le système
économique en europe j'ai pas si mes
collègues que partageant cet avis s'il
arrivait au pouvoir le madame thatcher
puis de monsieur régal qui n'a fait que
stephen âmes cette chaire est donc on
est passé d'un système où en gros on
accepter les régulations de marche fort
on avait vu une économie contrôlée par
l'état je fais très sain on a voulu tout
déréglementé et ça aussi il faut quand
même bien voir que l'union européenne
c'est d'une part cette volonté politique
de re de rassembler des pays mais c'est
aussi la volonté de créer un marché donc
et cette volonté a été transférée ont
créé un marché pour le pétrole à la
limite pourquoi pas mais il existait
d'ailleurs de toute façon on décide de
libéraliser le prix de l'essence comme
on l'a fait en 86 pourquoi pas c'est pas
totalement dramatique d'avis que ça va
monter à 2 euros mons et on voit que ça
bouge mais et je suis tout à fait
d'accord ça peut voir les conséquences
sur la vue il ya trois ans est léger et
j'ose avoir des conséquences importantes
ni empêche que le problème c'est que on
est sur les marchés du gaz sur le
fonctionnement du système gaz
électricité ce qu'on appelle des
monopoles naturels vous êtes chez vous
vous avez d'électricité on va pas être
de ligne de cou ligue l'occurrence pour
vous approvisionner donc on a mis en
place l'union européenne où il ya des
maniaques se dirait un petit peu du
marché à tout prix ont voulu absolument
appliquer à ces monopoles naturels et
même réel qu'on applique à la
marchandise qui sont les ventes de
pommes de betterave ou bien de bien des
sens et ça ça se traduit par des
systèmes extrêmement compliqué je
souhaite une fois vous avez la même
chose aux états unis je discutais avec
quelqu un que j comprenez rien jeu
passeur candy comprend encore maintenant
quelque chose mais je n'y comprenais
rien et je disais mais c'est quand même
système émises à ce système et les
américains me disais c'est une
conférence sur les mais nous même on ne
comprend pas très bien et hier on arrive
à des choses aberrantes ont fini par
être obligé de faire ce qu'on fait
actuellement c'est à dire de bloquer
complètement les prix mais aujourd'hui
je me disais mais on a bloqué les prix
complètement les distributeurs de lait
et l'idée c'est que les distributeurs
dont vont avancer la trésorerie des
c'est nécessaire et puis vont se
récupérer quand le prix du gaz va se
casser la figure peut-être au mois de
mai au mois d'avril mais on va pas
mettre en plein repas parler des
élections qui au milieu c'est encore
autre chose et enfin c'est pas les
français vont pas être épargnée par les
augmentations de prix il ya un moment on
peut se poser la question c'est à dire
que pour le moment c'est si bas c'est
bloqué donc mais qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer si vraiment on arrive à bloquer
le prix du gaz continuaient à monter les
opérateurs pourront pas opéré je ne suis
pas je ne cherche pas les défendre à
tout prix mais ça va pas marcher on a eu
cette situation en sur l'électricité aux
états unis au début des années 2000 et
les gens on parlait de 2,2 de collapse
by design c'est à dire de d'effondrement
du système par le dessin qui avait été
fait la construction qui avait été fait
de ce système on veut pas avoir des
systèmes effectivement comme là on va
l'avoir on capte les prix on les bloque
et puis en même temps le derrière le
marché des prix de gros fonctionne comme
il veut les sommes avancées vont devenir
considérable on a l'habitude depuis
quelques années depuis un an aux devoirs
des sommes importantes à arriver mais là
je vois pas trop bien comment si
vraiment le prix du gaz continuent à
monter moment ça va pouvoir vraiment
complètement fonctionné ou alors c'est
un pari sur l'avenir en fait on reporte
sur l'avenir d'ee des best seller baisse
de prix qui aurait dû à qui devrait
arriver d'ici ils ont le mieux l'année
prochaine ne seront pas répercutée dans
le meilleur des cas oui au cas où
effectivement le prix du gaz redescente
voilà c'est ça c'est ce qu'on attend
c'est ce sur quoi table en principe le
gouvernement continuera de payer de le
payer plus cher abu justement à regarder
on fait une pause dans une minute je
voulais ajouter quelque chose oui je
peux ajouter peut-être de petit
complément le premier complément c'est
qu'effectivement le gouvernement a pas
toujours la capacité de
impôts a empêché une évolution de tarifs
à un moment donné la commission de
régulation de l'énergie ou même où
conseil d'état lui rappellera à l'ordre
c'est à dire que c'est la loi qui
définit qui définit les tarifs ils
doivent refléter les coûts des
fournisseurs donc je pense que ça les
marges de manoeuvre sont limitées c'est
pour ça qu'on parle que d'un report
la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner c'était concernant le
leurs portes à l influence du prix de
marché de gros de l'électricité
sur le tarifs 1 le tarif du consommateur
en fait cette influence est plus
importante que celle que soliman pour
une raison un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué à expliquer mais dans la
période où le prix de marché de gros
était très très bas les fournisseurs
les fournisseurs concurrents d'edf sont
allés s'approvisionner sur le marché de
gros et donc ils ont au développer
énormément leur clientèle leur volume
d'affaires est bien quand le prix de
marché continue à repartir à la hausse
eh bien ils ont voulu bénéficier de la
part d'edf d'un de
de ce qu'on appelle la reine c'est à
dire un tarif très avantageux l'accès
régulé au nucléaire historique un des
retraites très avantageux qui leur
permettait de toujours fournir à leurs
clients une écrit cité à pied en france
électricité à bas prix et en fait ils
n'ont pas pu le faire parce que
il avait déjà un des volumes beaucoup
trop important et la loi limite et ce
volume qui leur était dédiée et donc du
coup ils ont dû s'approvisionner sur le
marché de gros et comme on veut
continuer à protéger
donc les fournisseurs concurrents d'edf
comme ils s'approvisionnent ce marché
groupe ils ont été
confrontées à des coûts beaucoup plus
important que ce qui pouvait avoir avec
la sécurité de l'accès au nucléaire
historique et en s'approvisionnant sur
ce marché growler leurs coûts donc à
augmenter donc leur prix potentiellement
à augmenter et par un élément enregistré
tiff un petit peu étrange mais on a
recalculé le tarif de façon à suivre le
coût des fournisseurs concurrents d'edf
c'est à dire pour qu' il puisse toujours
contesté le tarif toujours vendent moins
cher que le tarif est donc le mécanisme
de libéral que l'on a mis en place
conduit à ce type d' aberration c'est à
dire aujourd'hui finalement le tarif va
suivre les les coûts des fournisseurs
concurrents d'edf alors que ceux ci s
approvisionnent finalement sur le marché
et auprès d'un tarif réglementé donc je
veux cela explique assez nettement la
hausse
la hausse du tarif qui est annoncé je
vous interromps ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
elle serait de retour en france
l'inflation en un an les prix à la
consommation ont augmenté d'environ 9%
selon les dernières données de l'insee
vous avez aujourd'hui une impression qui
est plus due à une désorganisation
simuler des circuits de production et
des circuits de distribution plutôt que
une réelle inflation de la demande
l'inflation ressentie par les ménages ne
correspond pas forcément
à l'inflation qui est mesuré par l'insee
ce qui est prix de l'énergie loyer et
ses terrasses qui pèse très lourd dans
le budget des ménages qui sont en bas de
l'échelle sociale du coup se retrouvent
sous-estimé par ces instituts
conjoncture c'est quand même assez clair
pour moi c'est un chiffre qui est archi
politique donc de marketing politique
il pourrait quand même s'ils le
voulaient parce que c'est pas très
compliqué avoir des méthodes qui se
serait un petit peu plus réaliste
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
nous reprenons notre débat sur la hausse
continuelle des prix de l'énergie avec
jean pierre favennec à qui on doit
notamment un atlas mondial des énergies
avec thomas reverdy
l'auteur de la construction politique du
prix de l'énergie et avec anne debrégeas
ce qui est ingénieur et et chercheuse
chez edf ressources et développement et
qui milite au syndicat sud énergie le
pétrole le pétrole ne cesse d'augmenter
également chiites est tout à l'heure la
barre symbolique des 2 euros le litre
qui a été franchie dans l'est un petit
nombre de stations-service m'enfin c'est
important quand même ou si je vais
devenir qu'un marché en bretagne j'ai
quand même le pays un peu moins cher
mais qui comprenait deux euros et 2
euros oui c'est effectivement c'est
beaucoup et d'ailleurs c'est assez
étonnant on a vu le ministre prend des
mesures très fortes castex des mesures
très fortes contre la hausse du prix du
gaz et l'électricité ne rien dire
pratiquement sur l'augmentation des prix
de du pétrole alors qu'il ya trois ans
je le répète une hausse minime de
quelques centimes 1 minimes chez moi
qu'il dit de quelques centimes qui était
destiné en fait rétablir un certain
équilibre et surtout à décourager un peu
les gens d'utiliser des carburants il
émet du co2 dans la perspective de la
transition énergétique avait déclenché
la crise des gilets jaunes en dix ans
mais moi je je n'ai pas le choix pour
aller de chez moi à mon travail que de
prendre ma voiture donc si vous
augmentez la le prix de l'essence aux
deux carburants ou du gazole ça va bien
ça va être très difficile pour moi et là
on voit que les ya pas tellement de
réaction de ce côté-là nous dira d'où la
proposition et noorda d'hidalgo
candidate socialiste donc de baisser la
taxe et c'est sur les carburants at elle
dit mais voilà on peut baisser le prix
de l'essence ce sera d'ailleurs ces prix
de la transition énergétique tafer mais
voilà c'est exactement ce qu'a fait
d'ailleurs pour le gaz il me semble
premier ministre espagnol qui lui a
baissé les taxes sur le gaz pour réduire
le prix le problème d'ailleurs de la
baisse des taxes sur les carburants pour
savoir que quand on paye mettons à 80 le
litre on a pratiquement fait le pétrole
lui-même ne représente que 50 à 60
centimes on a après vincent t-il de tout
sport de logistique il restait des taxes
est là le problème de la saône a appelé
dans le temps la tpp flotte entière il
variabilité ces taxes c'est à dire que
les gouvernements pourraient jouer en
diminuant la taxe lorsque le prix du
pétrole augmente pour l'art et
augmentant lorsque prix du pétrole
diminue mais hier à matignon de certains
stabilité avait été largement discuté il
ya au moins une vingtaine d'années avait
été d'ailleurs abandonné à l'époque
sachant que l'on jouait sur le fait
qu'on économies il faut que le prix
reflète la réalité des coûts bon après
il ya l'aspect politique dont on vient
de parler longuement qui a évidemment
qu'il ya qui a également joué alors
justement thomas reverdy un aspect
politique pour vous dans le prix du
pétrole
était façon le prix que paye le
consommateur est souvent lié un choix en
fin et tout soit le résultat d'un choix
politique 1 ont peu et vous payez pas la
même et le mépris si vous êtes aux etats
unis quand vous quand vous utilisez
votre votre voiture que en europe par
exemple un et c'est aussi différent sein
des pays européens d'ailleurs le choix
n'est pas forcément le même en termes de
taxation entre
le consommateur final et puis le
transporteur routier donc il y à des
choix qui sont faits en termes de
taxation qui ont des effets très
importants sur
sur le prix du carburant
maintenant qu'elle est quelqu'un de
laquelle perspective il faut se placer
bien il faut je pense qu'il faut prendre
en compte le fait que
les ressources fossiles sont condamnés
quand même à terme à une beaucoup plus
grande rareté donc il faut les préserver
et puis surtout et bien on a un problème
de poubelle comme disent c'est à dire
qu'elles contribuent au au gaz et au gaz
à effet de serre est un gaz à effet de
serre quand même très important qui
vient de la consommation de ces énergies
fossiles et donc il est urgent de
refléter en tout cas par différents
moyens il ya différents moyens sont
possibles mais de refléter les ses
impacts environnementaux dans les choix
ddd consommateurs alors après soit vous
faites
des choix de d'augmenter la taxation
pour que ces coûts environnementaux
soient reflétées par le prix
d'achat la consommation soit vous pouvez
aussi intervenir par d'autres moyens
encourager d'autres modes de transport
entre encourager aussi enfin avoir des
politiques d'urbanisme le bannissent tic
qui
réduisent ou le transport avoir des
politiques d'économie circulaire qui
réduit ce transport de marchandises
voilà près vous pouvez faire tout un
ensemble de choix qui peuvent aussi
avoir des effets sur le transport sans
forcément passer uniquement par par le
prix même si c'est ça peut être un moyen
intéressant de 2,2 d'encourager la
réduction de ses consommations et puis
bien sûr le problème excusez moi je
termine le problème de ceux de
d'utiliser la l'augmentation des prix
pour
décourager la consommation une ressource
et qu'en fait vous allez d'abord
commencé à impacter ceux qui sont les
plus sensibles à cette hausse des prix
est à dire ceux qui ont les dépenses et
puis contraintes souvent et vous créer
des situations sociales qui sont qui
sont inextricables les situations
personnelles et qui sont vraiment très
problématique est donc effectivement
c'est pas c'est un levier qui ne doit et
ne peut être utilisée que si par
ailleurs vous faites de la
redistribution vers ces catégories
populations qui sont les n'est plus
étranglée sur le plan financier at the
borgias
oui je suis complètement d'accord avec
thomas reverdy le prix le prix l'énergie
ça doit être politique parce que c'est
un bien de première nécessité vont au
passage dans l'électricité encore une
fois le prix ne reflète pas du tout
aujourd'hui les coûts de production ça
rajoute du bruit de la volatile grande
volatilité totalement inutile et
contre-productive mais comme on a vu au
moment des gilets jaunes on n'empêche
pas les gens de prendre leur voiture en
subitement augmentant en augmentant
subitement pardon les le prix de
l'essence alors qu'ils sont contraints
d'aller au travail alors qu'ils ont
acheté une voiture thermique
alors qu'il ne les transports en commun
sont pas développés on commence par
investir sa demande des investissements
lourds de la planification dans les
transports en commun dans l'urbanisme
etc de la même matière de la même
manière pour l'énergie on entend
beaucoup finalement tant mieux cette
hausse de l'électricité ou du gaz elle
va permettre de réduire la consommation
enfin jusqu'à un certain stade
effectivement ça va plus peser sur les
sur les ménages précaires mais ce qui
joue beaucoup c'est 2 d'investir dans
des travaux d'isolation et aujourd'hui
c'est laisser aux marchés et les
résultats sont assez catastrophique et
puis pareil pour les énergies
renouvelables
on sort on sort des énergies fossiles
progressivement en planifiant sur le
long terme et en investissant or quand
on laisse les le marché fixer les prix
comme c'est aujourd'hui en tout cas
partiellement avec une volatilité
complètement énorme et absolument aucune
visibilité comment voulez vous que les
industriels investissent dans des
process qui vont leur permettre de
sortir des énergies fossiles pour aller
par exemple vers une électrification
moins polluants comment voulez vous
permettre aux ménages de s'isoler enfin
c'est juste impossible on n'avance pas
et je pense que c'est un des gros
problèmes de la libéralisation de
l'ouverture des marchés de l'électricité
non seulement ça ne fonctionne pas du
tout on voit sur le plan économique mais
en plus de ça ça freine ça entrave la
transition énergétique parce que on est
on tout le monde reconnaît qu'il faut
faire des investissements massifs et
urgent face à l'urgence climatique et
qu'est ce qu'on fait on laisse faire le
marché tous les acteurs y compris edf
disent qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens
d'investir parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
visibilité suffisante sur les retours
sur deux de leurs retours sur
investissement et on essaye de réparer
un système qui dysfonctionnent depuis sa
création la ce fait nous on sort de
trois ans de négociations autour d'un
projet de restructuration du marché
laiterie cité qui s'appelait hercules 3
ans après ici rien passé et les choses
continuent à évoluer continuer à se
détériorer et on est en continu enfin
moi c'est ce que je crains tu sais qu'on
continue à essayer de réparer ce système
qui ne peut pas fonctionner parce que il
faut écouter ce que disent les visages
et les consommateurs petits comme grands
industriels il dit nous on veut un prix
stable et lisible
c'est à dire non pas un prix de marché
oui tout à fait quand on dit que je
reviens on se disait un peu tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que la
libéralisation entre guillemets des
marchés du gaz électricité était quand
même assez catastrophique
on nous a promis d'ailleurs à l'origine
que ça va permettre de faire baisser les
prix vous l'avez très bien dit le prix
de l'électricité en fait à augmenter
donc et le fait que tout soit aussi
volatil après ne permet pas
effectivement de prendre des décisions
d'investissement donc il ya une époque
où edf était dirigée j'ai pas j'ai pas
spécialisés est restée comme on l'avait
connu des comprimés je m'intéresse
vivement à ces problèmes là les l'edf
était dirigée par en particulier
quelqu'un qui s'appelait marcel boiteux
qui avait imaginé un système de
tarification ça marchait assez bien je
me souviens pas d'avoir vu de gros
problèmes on avait un monopole de l'edf
qui gérait correctement les choses
étaient capables de construire tout le
système nucléaire est la dernière grande
décision colbertiste comme jeudi en
france a été quand le pierre messmer en
mars 2010 974 a dit fier de lancer
points d'écart on a construit 15 cents
peu pardon soit presque 60 centrales et
5 ans peut et qu'elle vend 70 ans
emprunte nucléaire en france en quinze
ans actuellement on a beaucoup de
problèmes pour en construire une ans je
sais pas combien d'années je vais pas
assister les pas j'ai pas mais trop d
j'aime bien qu'on viennent justement sur
sur le nucléaire parce que faisant
référence à cette décision des français
et tout nucléaire à l'époque pour se
préserver de la hausse des prix du
pétrole c'est tout à fait ce test mais
voilà
le magazine the economist il ya quelques
mois disait si tous les pays développés
avaient pas fait le même choix que la
france en 1973 aujourd'hui aurait pas de
réchauffement climatique or on est en ce
moment dans une tendance plutôt averses
tout le monde se retire du nucléaire et
donc le charbon augmente le gaz augmente
parce que l'allemagne l'autriche a2 qui
se retrouvent ce qui retient du
nucléaire nous mêmes les français on a
beau construire continuent et construit
des centrales ou proclame qu'on va se
retirer du nucléaire oui tout à fait non
mais ça moi j'hésite à parler du
nucléaire avec même des personnes qui
sont proches de moi que c'est
complètement émotionnel je suis désolé
je le présente comme ça c'est totalement
émotionnel les gens réagissent par
rapport à ça le nucléaire d'ailleurs
après on ya eu il ya eu trois accidents
nucléaires y en a eu 1 aux états unis
qui a été relativement limitées mais ces
données liés au syndrome chinois on
pensait le film bref voilà nos bilans
tchernobyl excusez moi on est entre nous
ça a été considéré comme un accident
particuliers liés à l'organisation orval
dire entre nos soviétique bon peut-être
donc on s'en est bien sorti et puis
après on sortait de tchernobyl ces 86 et
heureusement le nuage radioactif s'était
arrêté à la frontière donc ça s'était
très bien ne pas être trop menacés en
france et puis après on avait dans les
années 2000 ont commencé à reparler de
centrales nucléaires ont commencé à
avoir un renouveau du nucléaire il ya eu
fukushima il faut que shima cette espèce
d'énormes vagues de 20 mètres de haut
est venu s'abattre sur les côtes du
japon et le mur qui protège allée
centrale de fukushima ne faisait que dit
m simplifie sans doute et donc du coup
ça nous voyez les systèmes de deux il
faut que les réacteurs soit à un pearl
en permanence je parle sous contrôle
mais je suis pas très très expert mais
c'est un peu ce que j'ai en tête quand
même il faut ré fera dire le et les
systèmes de refroidissement ont été
noyés donc ils ont disparu et il ya eu
l'accident fukushima depuis fukushima
immédiatement le lendemain madame merkel
décidé de se retirer de d'arrêter le
nucléaire sans concertation avec les
européens alors que l'allemagne est au
centre du système le système comme
l'avait très bien dit il faut des
interconnexions dans tous les sens et
donc ils sont passés un système avec
beaucoup de renouvelables avec des
éoliennes en mer du nord avec des
panneaux solaires un peu dans le sud
ça c'est quand il ya du soleil et quand
il ya du vent ça marche très très bien
mais si son état la nuit et qui a pu
devant il faut faire marcher les
centrales soit au charbon et au gaz on
revient aux problèmes que l'on a évoqué
très bien d'ailleurs en disant que
puisque la le coût de l'électricité au
gaz augmentent du fait de ces pénalités
qu'on lui impose je reviens pas sur les
détails on passe au gaz et comme le prix
du gaz augmente et comme c'est le prix
de l'électricité produite à partir des
gars s'il devient un peu dominant menées
sur ces fameux marchés où le coût
marginal jouent un rôle fondamental
voilà bah de manière regrettable
d'ailleurs on a effectivement les
augmentations faramineuses at the
borgias sur le nucléaire
franchement c'est un sujet complètement
différent de l'organisation des marchés
parce que ce qu'on a dit sur le fait que
les coûts sont essentiellement fixe que
la part du les énergies fossiles est
petit et va devenir de plus en plus
petit c'est vrai quel que soit le choix
qu'on prenne sur sortir ou pas du
nucléaire ce qui fait la flambée des
prix aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec le
fait enfin normalement ça devrait pas
être le cas puisque on a une énergie
nucléaire mais c'est vraiment la
construction et du marché qui fait ça où
est ce que je pense c'est que c'est une
décision lourde de conséquences est-ce
qu'on sort ou pas du nucléaire il ya
plusieurs choix qui s'offre à nous
clairement qu'ils sont maintenant
documenté rtl havane mégawatts va sortir
l'association négawatt va sortir des
scénarios et rtl va sortir des scénarios
qu'on fait l'objet d'une très large
concertation scénario pour certains ou
au maintien l'option nucléaire à 50% -
et des scénarios 100% renouvelable il
estime que c'est faisable techniquement
après ça un coup il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de solution miracle donc c'est
un coup bas pour le nucléaire
effectivement il ya un risque je pense
que personne ne peut le nier y compris
nos directeur de la recherche
aujourd'hui 10 enfin nous souhaitons
qu'on était au moment de tchernobyl il
dit au moment de fukushima disait le
risque zéro n'existe pas il ya le
problème des déchets et puis le
renouvelable ça pose aussi des questions
effectivement faut accepter de mettre
des éoliennes
à beaucoup d'endroits du solaire etc bon
je pense que c'est à la population de
décider ça il faut un débat public sur
la question c'est un sujet majeur qui
nous engage pour des décennies hélas ce
que je vois qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est qu'on sent des pressions pour 100
m attend les résultats que de rte ou si
ça sort j'ai peur que ce soient pas
débattues qui est des pressions par
derrière de lobby dont edf il faut bien
lire pour dire on relance l'option
nucléaire tout de suite sans débat
public et sans même attendre la fin la
construction de la première centrale le
p r pas de le père de flamanville pour
l'instant on n'est pas à terme le mari
vers des choses à dire sur le nucléaire
oui je pense que ce qui ce qui importe
en avoir en tête c'est que l'on
bénéficie effectivement en france
historique fin d'un nucléaire qui a été
construit il ya maintenant quelques
décennies qui est
très performant qui dans les coûts sont
assez intéressants
par rapport à d'autres d'autres
solutions par contre effectivement
c'est un nucléaire qui est aussi
vieillissant donc potentiellement il va
falloir le remplacer si on peut
maintenir un très haut niveau de
sécurité ou bien alors effectivement
accepté aussi des investissements
importants dont on connaît pas forcément
toujours la teneur donc ça veut dire que
la période d'une électricité et
peut-être un coût maîtrisé où on va se
retrouver face à une hausse des
probablement de des coûts de production
d'électricité avec ses besoins soit de
prolongement soit de remplacement du
nucléaire historique alors après
effectivement je partage tout à fait
l'idée de hann c'est à dire qu'il faut
un débat public documenté
rigoureux
avec avec une expertise solide celle de
rte peut être effectivement est
probablement l'un des meilleurs
expertise dans le domaine pour pour
pouvoir alimenter un débat public et
faire un choix un choix
entre ses différentes stratégies
de pour remplacer effectivement le
nucléaire historique mais la question va
aussi se poser progressivement de
laquelle rythme on le remplace est ce
qu'on accélère ce remplacement ou au
contraire est-ce qu'on profite
avec quelques risque évidemment de cette
cette ressource j'obtiens favennec le
charbon on a tendance à l'oublier chez
nouvelle
le charbon il sert encore dans nombreux
pays oui ben en allemagne en particulier
le prix monte là où sont les allemands
qui je n'ai absolument rien contre son
camp 1 et grand défenseur de
l'environnement sont quand même de très
loin ceux qui émettent le plus de co2 en
europe parce que et si vous allez en
pologne c'est encore pire puisque
l'essentiel est à partir de le charbon
ou alors il ya des techniques on ne
parle pas beaucoup d'une technique on
appelle la capture et le stockage du co2
c'est un peu bizarre comme non ça veut
dire tout simplement que ce fameux co2
dont on ne veut pas on essaie de le
capturer et de leurs ayants fuir dans le
sol un peu de temps si ça peut exister
ça peut se faire ça peut se faire c'est
compliqué mais ça fait 30 ans qu'on en
parle et en fait on ne progresse pas
beaucoup là dessus en plus il falloir
expliquer quand même pas jusqu'à un très
très conscient vous avez raison de
parler de débat public le jour on va
être qu'il ya des gens qu'on va rien
réinjecter du co2 sous leurs pieds ça va
être assez compliqué je comprends très
bien la notion de débat public je suis
pas certain que dans les conditions
actuelles on puisse avoir des débats
publics serein même si c'est qu'on est
nécessaire même façon sur les choix
entre les différents types d'énergie que
ce soit nucléaire les et les
renouvelables moi personnellement
pendant je ne vois pas de solution
vraiment rationnelles à tout à toute
cette évolution qu'on doit faire vers la
transition énergétique parce que certes
il faut sortir des énergies fossiles de
manière à éviter émissions de co2 mais
même si on oublie tous les problèmes
qu'on peut voir autour des éoliennes et
du solaire avec le solaire encore le
moins critique on est actuellement quand
même à des proportions relativement
faible même au niveau mondial même dans
les pays qui sont les plus avancées un
pays comme le danemark et 50 % de son
électricité à partir d'éoliennes mais
pourquoi parce que vous avez à côté un
pays qui s'appelle la norvège où il ya
des chutes d'eaux énormes et lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de vent et bien le danemark
importe son oeuvre en électricité de la
norvège quand il ya du vent mer on
arrête les barrages et puis on attend
mais c'est des solutions particulières
donc c'est assez compliqué je ne vois
pas de départ en tête une solution
vraiment nabeul à ce problème de
transition énergétique même si ça me
paraît totalement nécessaire il devra y
as
encore une fois je pense que enfin il
faut vraiment se plonger dans les
scénarios à eux parce que c'est
exactement ça qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire
qu'ils font des scénarios
alors tout ce qu'ils atteignent la
neutralité carbone ses hypothèses de
départ donc ils se passent complètement
de gaz fossile et effectivement ils
n'ont parcouru ensemble à la captation
de co2 qui pourrait aussi être une
option dans prises dans certains pays
mais il fonde et ils font des
trajectoires il explique année par année
comment comment on développe alors soit
soit effectivement on ne se base que sur
l'éolien et le solaire et on utilise
l'hydrogène qui est lui-même créé par
électrolyse de l'eau donc avec de
l'électricité pour pour lisser la
production tout au long de l'année
notamment faire face aux pics d'hiver
soit on laisse une part de nucléaire qui
va de toute façon être appelées à
diminuer pour faire ce lissage sachant
que dans l'idéal effectivement il
faudrait se coordonner avec les autres
pays européens puisque le réseau est
interconnecté et on a intérêt à jouer la
solidarité et la coopération entre pays
mais bon ça c'est c'est plus difficile
dernier mot les conséquences les prix de
l'énergie augmentent le gaz le pétrole
l'électricité
il y aura des conséquences forcément sur
les biens de consommation que les
entreprises sont en train de produire
tout ça risque de recréer de l'inflation
thomas reverdy
tout d'abord enfin il faut en tête que
on a vécu dans un univers où finalement
l'énergie était devenu
finalement a très très peu coûteuse
c'est à dire que sa part dans les coûts
de nos biens dans les coûts de dornot
mode de vie était devenue très faible
parce qu'elle était abondante pour
marcher surtout l'énergie fossile mais d
autres l'énergie nucléaire on a un peu
parlé aussi un était devenu aussi donc
on va on va aller forcément vers un vers
un monde économique ou à nouveau
l'énergie à nouveau parce que dans le
passé ce n'était pas le cas
historiquement
l'énergie était beaucoup moins
disponibles et avait une part bien plus
importante dans en termes de coûts dans
nos modes de vie et donc aujourd'hui on
va probablement aller vers vers une
économie qui va devoir prendre en compte
davantage cette variable parce que ne
serait-ce que réduire
réduire d'abord adopter des modes de
production de l'énergie qu'ils sont au
moins impactants qui va nécessairement
augmenter leurs coûts ensuite réduire
évidemment là que la consommation
énergétique parce que il n'ya pas de
mode de production mais qui n'a pas
d'impact environnemental significatif
donc il va falloir adopter des modes de
production qui sont moins consommateurs
d'énergie être beaucoup plus vigilant
dans les choix des technologies
industrielles qu'on utilise et puis il
va falloir aussi con reconcevoir les
produits avoir des modes de conception
de produits qu'ils soient là aussi moins
consommateurs et puis probablement des
modes de vie qui se dépendront peut-être
moi enfin de la consommation matérielle
c'est à dire que que l'on soit en phase
d'aidé finalement des choix de modes de
consommation et de mode de vie qui ne
sont pas que la consommation matérielle
à la consommation culturelle
consommation de services il ya plein
d'autres manières de
consommer de se développer 2 que que la
consommation matérielle voilà donc ce
que voilà voilà lui n'y va falloir agir
sur tous les tableaux de tte façon
d'accord sur les conséquences je vais
être un petit peu j'étais un peu
provocateur je veux dire que je suis un
bon européen je vit confortablement en
france si on dit bah tu prends moins ta
voiture tu prends un vélo même mais la
casse etc je veux bien tout ça mais il
faut allez expliquer ça ou rose indien
je fais souvent la comparaison entre ces
deux il ya deux énormes pays qui
s'appelle la chine et l'inde ils ont à
peu près le même population la chine
c'est 4 fois l'inde attend sa
consommation etc je veux bien mais il va
être quand même compliqué d'expliquer à
des indiens qui sortent à peine pour
l'essentiel d'une période de pauvreté va
voir changer de comportement etc les
malheureux ils ont on a vu des scènes
affreuses où on voyait à ces gens qui
partaient qui marche et c'est donc je
comprends bien ce qui est dit alors
monsieur reverdy mais je pense qu'on est
dans un monde qui est quand même qui
dépasse largement la france et l'union
européenne et que c'était quelque chose
d'assez compliqué les chinois ont pris
des engagements en matière de
changements climatiques en disant qu'ils
vont réduire leurs émissions de co2 ils
sont déjà peut-être pas bon presque en
état de le faire d'autres pays à travers
le monde paraît beaucoup en afrique
savoir qu'un africain il ya eu trois
fois moins d'argent qu'un européen donc
lui dire qu'il faut qu'ils commencent à
changer j'aurais cru beaucoup de voix à
30 fois une fois excusez moi je suis
trompé donc il faut lui expliquer qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent un peu attention à
ces modes de vie ça va être compliqué et
je crois qu'ils sont prêts à 7e de vie
européen
anne debrégeas
c'est sûr que ça non je monte mondiale
bon il faut quand même qu'on fasse notre
part notre part des choses mais que ce
soit en europe ou ailleurs ça paraît
évident on voit les répercussions sur
l'ensemble de l'économie on va voir les
interactions aussi sur la précarité
énergétique qui va déjà très présente et
qui va augmenter on voit que l'énergie
et n'est pas un bien comme les noms
comme les autres c'est un bien de
première nécessité et à ce titre là il
faut absolument une tarification un prix
qui soient garantis par la puissance
publique et qu'ils soient sortis du
marché absolument sortie de marché non
seulement avec l'ouverture des marchés
on a déjà perdu nous en français comme
en europe l'égalité de traitement
c'est-à-dire qu'il ya des offres
maintenant qu'ils sont négociés de gré à
gré par les différents fournisseurs ce
qui est quand même embêtant on a exposé
les gens et les entreprises à des prix
non seulement qu ont énormément augmenté
mais qui sont extrêmement volatiles ce
qui est ce qu'il ya un gros problème
voilà je pense qu'il faut maintenant
sortir de là
horaires réfléchir à ce que doit être
l'énergie planifié effectivement
coopérer avec les pays qui sont dans une
phase eu d'accès à l'énergie et ne pas
aller voir comme un marché potentiel
aussi enfin bref revenir à un service
public et ça c'est urgent d'autant plus
qu'il faut des investissements massifs
et que si ce n'est pas la puissance
publique qui fait cet investissement
et ils ont ils ont la possibilité de le
faire aujourd'hui l'état peut emprunter
a très peu cher si on s'adresse aux
privés ça coûte beaucoup plus cher etc
et on perd notre souveraineté sur bien
qui est hautement stratégique on voit
aujourd'hui je vous remercie tous les
trois devant participer à ce débat merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]